in this video we'll be talking about
astrocytes when we think about our brain
we can have neuronal cells
and alongside the neuronal cells we have
other cell types known as glia astrocyte
is one type of glia by the way
alongside astrocytes there are many
other glial cell types in brain such as
microglia oligodendrosite and each of
these cell type have their defined role
and they interact with each other
and that's what is important for the
brain function
in this video we'll be talking more
about the astrocyte
so let's talk about
astrogliogenesis that means how
astrocytes are born
so in the brain neurogenesis happens
from the radial glial cell progenitors
so radial glial cell projectors can
divide and give rise to a new radial
clear or it can give rise to a newborn
neuron
but this happens in the very early stage
of the brain development as the brain
develops more eventually these
neurogenic progenitor which were
supposed to give rise to neuron switch
their fate to a gliogenic progenitor now
these progenitors instead of giving rise
to neuron would eventually give rise to
astrocytes
so that means
astrocytes are born from the later
derived radial clear itself
so neurogenesis to cleogenesis which is
an active area of research in
developmental neuroscience
let's talk about the functions of
astrocytes and how astrocytes are
important for our brain
so astrocytes play a vital role in the
brain
astrocytes participate in synapse
formation and they regulate synaptic
activity
secondly astrocytes participate in blood
brain barrier formation
each of these two functions are very
important for Brin
proper functionality and brain
development as well
so let's talk about the how astrocyte
can regulate glutamate glutamine cycle
at the synapse
because
astrocytes key role is to form that
tripartite synapse that means one neuron
synapsing with another and astrocyte
being the third component in the
synaptic cohort
so glutamate is one of the major
neurotransmitter in vertebrate brain
so glutamate is an excitatory
neurotransmitter that means it lead to a
excitatory change in the post synapse
so here is a synapse in a zoomed in
version It's a glutameter chicks synapse
so in the this is the prison apps this
is the post synapse and this is the
astrocyte forming the third component of
the tripartite synapse
when the action potential reach the
nerve terminal there would be release of
neurotransmitter in the synaptic cleft
and that would bind to The glutametergic
receptors on the post synapse this is a
glutamatergic synapse so obviously the
neurotransmitter is glutamate and The
postsynaptic receptors are glutamate
receptors
so glutamate is synthesized from
glutamine in the neurons
and this is done by the enzyme
glutaminase
now actually glutamine comes from the
astrocyte and glutamine is uptaken by
the neuron and converted to the
glutamate and loaded onto these vesicles
now question is
how does astrocyte help
so in the synaptic cleft glutamate is
not there for eternity
glutamate is released it stays there for
a while but eventually the glutamate
would be uptaken by the astrocytes and
this is done by excitatory amino acid
transporters
that is how astrocytes ensure that extra
glutamate can be removed quickly and
that might not lead to an over
activation of the synapse
astrocyte convert glutamate into
glutamine with the help of glutamine
synthetase and bring back that glutamine
that means the raw material to produce
glutamate in the neuron and this is how
the glutamine glutamate cycle happens in
a tripartite synapse
so it turns out too much glutamate is
actually bad when there is too much
glutamate there is high level of
excitability uncontrolled excitability
this situation is known as
excitotoxicity or glutamate induced
excitotoxicity
and these kind of excited toxicity-like
situation can lead to death of the
neuron and this happens in many diseases
one such example could be epilepsy where
there is hyper excitability and too much
glutamate
so excess glutamate in the synaptic
cleft is a big problem that can be
solved by the astrocytes because
astrocyte can uptick some of the
glutamate and maintain these balance so
this is a very important role for proper
synaptic functioning
now astrocyte can also secrete
gliotransmitter this is a concept that's
not present in the textbook but this is
a really recent concept it turns out it
is thought that okay astrocyte can also
participate in synaptic communication
there are specific type of uh
neurotransmitter that is secreted by the
neurons which can also be uh
recepted by the astrocyte nfts and
astrocyte can in response release
gliotransmitters which can also
influence neuronal activity so they talk
to each other in a bi-directional way
and what is the implication of these
bi-directional crosstalk is still a
active area of research
now astrocytes form or help to form the
blood print barrier so inside our brain
there are so many blood vessels but
everything that is inside the blood
cannot reach our brain because there is
a selectivity filter and that is the
blood print barrier it prevents random
thing or random solute in circulating in
the blood
to prevent to enter the brain
so this is the brain and this is the
blood it prevents all the solute
molecule to pass
but how that is useful
so blood print barrier restricts the
passage of pathogens
harmful metabolites large hydrophilic
molecules inside the brain and it allows
the
selective permeabilization of certain
substances such as glucose and other
molecules which are absolutely essential
for the brain so this is how one portion
of the blood-brain barrier look like so
this is a blood vessel and you can see
there are capillary endothelial cells
there are astrocytic feeds there are
pericites which forms these blood brain
barrier
so the blood print barrier is actually
at a molecular level the tight junctions
between the endothelial cells this allow
the diffusion of CO2 O2 hormones and
small polar molecules but it prevents
the passage of plethora of molecules
when we think about astrocytes
they are homogeneous population or
heterogeneous population one of the
classical view they were like astrocytes
they are homogeneous population in the
brain but with the development of
current methodologies it has been seen
that they are not homogeneous they are
extremely heterogeneous population and
these kind of understanding came from
the development of single cell RNA
sequencing from the mouse brain when
single cell RNA sequencing was performed
it was observed that there are several
different types of astrocyte which has
unique molecular signatures
question is do they have unique
functionality
and it's also important to note that
these type of astrocytes are present in
different proportion in the different
brain regions
questioning its functionality and
influence on brain development so this
is also an area of active research where
scientists are trying to understand how
astrocyte diversity is important for the
brain
now not only astrocyte diversity when we
think about a cell we should also think
about cellular States just like we are
sometimes angry and happy astrocytes
could be sometimes reactive as well that
means they are super angry or pathogenic
so this reactive astrocyte concept is a
newly developed concept and these
reactive astrocytes are heavily
implicated in disease pathology
let me give you some examples so
astrocytes are implicated in several
neurodegenerative and neurodevelopmental
disorders
so one such very common example is the
involvement of astrocytes in Alzheimer's
disease in the Alzheimer's disease there
are pathological Hallmarks which we
already know the beta amyloid plaques so
the astrocytes interact with the
betamyloid pluck and it can also
interact with the microglial cells which
ultimately lead to a overall
inflammation so microglial cells
interact with secretes certain molecules
which are
converting the astrocyte to a reactive
State making them kind of angry and that
sort of like has had an adverse effect
in terms of neural inflammation so the
point is
recite microglia and neurons talk to
each other
and The Language by which they talk is
via cytokines
and ultimately these kind of crosstalks
lead to brain damage and neural
inflammation and that is a common
pathology for many disorders not only
Alzheimer's disease but it has been
implicated in Huntington's scoria also
in amyotropic lateral sclerosis these
are recent understanding and the
literature link is provided in the
description if you just want to take a
look at it
now so let us summarize what we learned
about astrocytes so first we talked
about the function two major function in
the brain one is it take part in the
neuromodulation and the synaptic
activity and the second thing is take it
is taking part to form the blood brain
barrier which prevents harmful substance
to come in then we looked at and focused
at how astrocyte modulate the synaptic
function we talked about the
gliotransmitters
we also focused some aspects of the
blood brain barrier formation and
ultimately we looked at how astrocytes
are involved in neurological disorders
so I hope this was useful if you like
this video give it give it a big thumbs
up don't forget to like share and
subscribe all my social media links are
provided in the description don't forget
to follow us support our Channel using
super thanks which is a hardship icon
with Dollar in it in the right side of
your video you can click on it and pay
via paytm PayPal or UPI
stay tuned for more